Selita Ebanks the Victoria's Secret
model hmm
she also this week came out and said
that her ex-husband Nick Cannon had a
small piece
oh he's do that married right there yeah
why do I have to know how big everyone's
dick is why can't women stop saying this
stuff yeah good point
especially if your name's Nick Cannon
how disappointing is that yeah really
change your name to Nick derringer what
are you gonna do what are your choices
Nick peashooter yeah I'll save everyone
the trouble I have a really small dick
well then see that is your prerogative
you can say that about yourself if you
want I have a huge [ __ ] but I don't
around talking about it so I think it's
up to each man to say whether whatever
he wants to say about his penis but no
one else should have that conversation
even though again mine is huge I don't
choose to bring it up in mixed company
fair enough
did I mention my low-hanging balls if
I'd like this much much bigger than that
it's party Mike as far as you know yes
low-hanging balls
I do have low hangars what do you call
Junkers yeah my wife has heard
screeching until the night we're in a
hotel toilet that's different than our
own at home ah what water's cold
I've hit water your balls go into the
toilet yeah that deeply yeah have you
ever flushed in Malaga I was once in an
airplane I got sucked out over Toledo
with the blue eyes
[Music]